the taliban have advanced to the gates
of the afghan capital kabul sources say
the insurgents have pushed into the
outskirts but a taliban spokesperson
said the militants have been ordered not
to enter the city it is a breathtaking
development coming just over a week
after the taliban launched a lightning
speed advance across the country
helicopters have been landing at the u.s
embassy in kabul as washington and other
western governments scrambled to
evacuate diplomatic staff
a tweet from the afghan presidential
palace said gunfire had been hurt in
several locations around kabul but that
security forces in coordination with
international partners remained in
control of the city
well journalist franz marty is in the
afghan capital kabul and he joins us now
for the very latest so franz uh we're
hearing the reports that the taliban
have entered kabul's outskirts but also
that its fighters have been instructed
not to take the city by force
what are you hearing
yes there have been reports that they
entered the city it's really hard to
verify uh probably they have in some
parts in the outskirts and this then
created a panic and i'd like to reports
that they enter from everywhere which
doesn't seem to be true taliban
spokesman as was said in your report uh
said that they were ordered to like
remain outside the city the latest is
now that um the interior minister of the
afghan government has said that there
won't be an attack on kabul uh and that
there will be
a negotiated surrender and there are now
rumors that uh mula baghdad the leader
of the taliban political office is uh
heading to kabul um so it seems that
there will be a negotiated surrender and
not a forceful takeover
and yet it was just yesterday that
afghan president ashraf ghani addressed
the nation and he promised to
re-mobilize government forces
have you seen any evidence of
preparations by the afghan military to
defend kabul
there have been reports that some people
were recruited yesterday evening a
well-known general was appointed to lead
the defense of kabul
um whether there have been like
practical preparation it's hard to tell
um ganesh rani's statement yesterday
seemed already then like detached from
reality
as it was hard to imagine
how given the last few days
how the security forces would be able to
make a lost stand after they literally
before did mostly nothing and let just
cities fall so that this would be a
u-turn and all of a sudden they would be
able to defund kabul
uh was already like questionable
yesterday
well it is looking increasingly likely
that it's just a matter of time that the
taliban will manage to seize control of
kabul and then effectively of the entire
country
so once that does happen how do you
expect the taliban to govern afghanistan
i mean do we have to expect a return to
the same kind of oppressive and brutal
rule we saw in the past
the thing is this the polygon have
despite like being engaged in like
negotiations with the united states and
then later death and government the
taliban have been very consistent they
have never like compromised much so they
have always said they want an islamic
system and
right between the lines it is more or
less that they will call the shots what
is islamic and what is on islamic um so
they have since years said they want uh
to take full power and implement their
vision of islam so we have to to expect
something akin to the former taliban
emirate the taliban have become more
media savvy also during the past week it
has shown that
they showed clemency
to surrendering forces
this will probably like continue but the
taliban will become all of a sudden like
liberal
that's not going to happen so it will be
akin to to what happened before uh maybe
with a better pr phase and a little bit
softer so to speak
we have also seen
little or even no resistance to taliban
forces seizing many of the provincial
capitals now is this because of their
superior military might or does the
taliban actually have support among the
afghan population
and polymon have some support of amongst
african population otherwise you
wouldn't have been able to like sustain
this insurgency how much is difficult to
tell
um
in my opinion but this is just a guess
most people are not very supportive of
the taliban but they are also not
supportive of the government and what
happened uh
what like facilitated this collapse was
less that i would say less that that
people switch side to the taliban but
more that they lost confidence in the
current government
and thought that uh yeah the government
is lost and then inevitably the taliban
will take over and uh the more that then
province is surrendered the more this
kind of momentum accelerated and the
dominoes began to fall
and yeah now it's more or less
game over
journalist franz marty speaking to us
from kabul we appreciate your reporting
thank you
well for germany's perspective on all
these developments in afghanistan i'm
now joined in the studio by dw's
political correspondent and madwell
hello to you emma
have there been any official reactions
from the german government to the events
of uh today in afghanistan well there's
been a reaction actually yesterday from
foreign minister haikomas to the general
situation in afghanistan he said
two things that i would like to mention
here he said that first germany would
not allow its citizens to fall into the
hands of the taliban and should the
taliban come to uh power in afghanistan
while germany would seize all financial
aid it had been uh provided afghanistan
with for years this is 430 million euros
per year that goes into also
humanitarian aid financial aid for
the reconstruction of the country so
that would be a severe blow also to the
afghan population and of course the
priority right now for germany is to
evacuate uh german
people still in afghanistan as well as
local staff and there's been a lot of
critics against the government for not
doing it sooner
right so now we are hearing reports that
the german military is planning to
evacuate german nationals uh beginning
on monday what can you tell us about
those plans exactly so first it wasn't
clear whether charter
flights or military flights would would
repatriate people still in afghanistan
german still in afghanistan apparently
now starting on monday military planes
would actually
bring people embassy personnel around uh
20 people as well as local staff that
will be around 300 people first to
tashken in tashkent in uzbekistan then
back to germany as well as a hundred
german nationals who are still in
afghanistan at the moment and so far
there's around 800 local staff already
repatriated in germany with the interior
ministry saying that they're saying that
there was no
time for you know for bureaucracy right
now and that a visa will be issued when
those people come off out of the plane
in germany
now emma germany was of course part of
the nato-led mission in afghanistan it
deployed soldiers there back in 2002 and
over the past 19 years
the german army actually suffered more
fatalities than
in any other deployment abroad since the
second world war how do germans view
then the withdrawal of the bundeswehr
from afghanistan in light of the
developments that we're seeing with the
taliban seizing control well you
mentioned the death toll for the german
army 59
soldiers lost their lives in afghanistan
and the last 570 soldies were
repatriated back in june and for many
german veterans you know there's a
feeling of helplessness and also
many interrogations as to what will
become
of the afghan people and also of all the
local stuff uh which has uh which have
helped the german army while they were
on the ground there's also feeling of uh
perhaps their engagement in afghanistan
not having uh you know helped uh for
much uh it's also you know we also have
to keep in mind that there are so many
afghans who live in germany at the
moment
000 afghans are here
30 000 were fe were facing deportation
those deportations have been temporarily
halted uh on wednesday so
in the german population there's a lot
of interrogations as to which role
germany played in afghanistan and was it
worth it
dw political correspondent emmanuel
ashes thank you so much
well we'll have more analysis coming up
but first here's a look at the city of
jalalabad which fell to the taliban
earlier on sunday
the streets of jalalabad afghanistan's
eastern gateway
normally a hive of activity
now people just wait apprehensively
on sunday morning residents awoke to
find the city in the hands of the
taliban there was no fighting no
resistance
those soldiers of the afghan national
army who haven't fled gave up their arms
in return for letters of amnesty from
taliban commanders just as in herat and
other towns
[Music]
i was a member of the afghan forces in
the zafar corps then i was surrounded by
the taliban and now i've come here to
get an amnesty letter so i can leave the
city and find somewhere safe to stay
the capital kabul is the last major
urban area under government control
the city appears calm but hundreds of
people are hurriedly trying to withdraw
their life savings
amongst the fear and resignation there's
also defiance they are here i'm not
afraid of them we are not the people who
will you know go back to the dark era
i'm a girl and i don't care about anyone
not pakistan not america nobody else i'm
here even today if they kill me if they
identify me i will not care about them
i will not care about them what should i
be scared of this is my homeland
president ashraf ghani who on saturday
spoke to the nation for the first time
since the taliban offensive began
appears increasingly isolated warlords
he negotiated with just days ago have
surrendered to the taliban or fled
leaving ghani without a military option
and with no negotiating power
as government control collapses the u.s
military has sent helicopters to kabul
to extract embassy staff and locals who
worked with the americans and who now
fear bloody reprisals
well for some analysis we can speak to
marcus caim he is from the german
institute for international and security
fairs thank you so much for being on our
program
so after nearly 20 years of war nato and
u.s troops are leaving afghanistan
behind
largely as they found it
is what we're seeing now in kabul an
unavoidable result
it is the unavoidable result of a major
decision taken by president biden in
april to withdraw u.s troops from
afghanistan unconditionally
and that's the major difference to his
predecessor donald trump who was already
negotiating the withdrawal of u.s troops
now it's unconditional unconditional and
political terms unconditional in
military terms and that has give
tremendous
power to the taliban and led to the
major withdrawal of all nato forces and
what we see happening in these days and
weeks is the result of the u.s policy
decision taken in april which reflects a
major disappointment
which were
what has been accomplished in our in
afghanistan over the last 20 years in
terms of security and good governance
so what then was germany hoping to
achieve when it joined the u.s led nato
mission in afghanistan
i think the three german goals are
quickly quite easy to identify the first
one has been
to express solidarity after the attacks
of 9 11 and that
has been the major police foreign policy
goal of this endeavor
and with this germany has been quite
successful if you talk to people in the
united states it's well recognized that
germany participated for 20 years in
this difficult mission the second goal
is to contribute to fight counter to to
contribute to counter terrorism
to fight al-qaeda that has been
accomplished the second goal has been
accomplished to a certain degree
al-qaeda still exists but it's not
capable to uh to
perpetrate
major attacks in western capitals
but the third goal has not been
accomplished to build up
robust effective security forces in
afghanistan which are capable to cope
with the taliban we have focused on the
numbers that we have
350 000 soldiers and policemen were
focused on the degree of the
training and the quality of the
equipment but at the end of the day it
was a political
decision and to withdraw all forces for
political reasons
and now will these developments in
afghanistan
clearly the strategic goal
have not been met
will it make it germany less likely to
join allies in other foreign deployments
in the future
absolutely i think no major
international organization beat the
european union or be nate will take over
any kind of major large-scale stability
operation like afghanistan
uh any anytime soon there's no political
appetite and if you talk to people here
in berlin you hear exactly the same tone
after the
difficult and disappointing experience
about what has been accomplished in
afghanistan after 20 years after the
huge financial investments after the
huge military investments after the
blood was what
has been fed in afghanistan everybody's
so disappointed what has been
accomplished i think there's a major
decision not to get
involved in any
of these kinds of missions soon
marcus keim from the german institute
for international and security affairs
thank you so much for sharing your
insights with us
thank you
all right let's get the view from the
united states now and for that dw
correspondent stefan simons joins us now
from washington dc hello to you steph
and i know it's a bit early in
washington where you are but has there
been an official reaction yet on what
has been happening in kabul
no there has not i'm afraid i can't give
you that so far let's wait a few more
hours as you see in the background me
there's the lights are off inside the
white house so there is at least for us
to see no activity yet speaking of any
reactions from the white house from this
administration from the biden
administration on this on the latest
developments in kabul and regarding the
talibans
on march or onslaught towards the uh
capital of afghanistan nor has there be
any reaction today or this early morning
on a sunday in the united states from
the other
side of the political spectrum speaking
the gop or the republicans so no
reactions yet but they will come in the
next few hours that is for sure
well all of this week the taliban have
been seizing control of one provincial
capital after another in afghanistan and
seemingly without much resistance
many governments around the world appear
to be very surprised by this was the us
also surprised
i think it's fair to say that they were
we heard just a few days ago
uh
military or intelligence assessments uh
which said oh the taliban are marching
towards kabul yes that's true but
um
20 years of investment hundreds of
billions of dollars into their military
apparatus as well in command structure
the latest military gear
made in usa in the hands of afghan
national security forces that should
bring the taliban not right now and
within 24 or 48 hours to the doorstep of
kabul but it should take between 30 and
90 days so a month or three months so
obviously that didn't turn out yesterday
you see yesterday on saturday was a good
indicator that the president ordered
more troops into afghanistan to the
hamid karzai international airport in
kabul now there are 5 000 troops there
and it was supposed to be 3 000 or 3 and
a half thousand
before that so a rapid increase of more
troops helping with the evacuation um of
the us personnel in the u.s embassy that
was an indicator that the taliban
actually
yeah almost like in a um
i have the words other words for like
almost like a blitz creek a tempo um
marching towards kabul this was i think
a surprise even for u.s intelligence and
military and now yesterday if you give
me the time to just let me mention that
yesterday there were some opposing
voices out here in washington saying
like okay where was the planning of the
administration for this um you know
military they have a plan a plan b plan
c and then they all go out of the window
and then there's a plan d for everything
uh which happens then at least that's
what the military said so there is
questions if those if those plans
existed and if the administration really
was prepared to something like this a
scenario like we have now
all right dw correspondent stefan simons
reporting from washington d.c
thank you so much
you